so i mean you mentioned building schools
and stuff in afghanistan yeah yeah
that's that's a that is amazing i have a
lot of respect for that
at right now i wonder why it is what we
focus on things like that
well i mean this coveted bill i tried to
jump to this a little bit too early in
the intro of your show but um
i have a lot of issues with this coved
bill on a number of different levels one
of which is a process issue right like
the idea that
a 5 300 page bill
is given to congress with what three or
four hours to read
before they actually vote on the bill i
got a huge problem with that right
um it's it's it's i would say we should
all have more than a problem with it
that they are telling us
screaming in our faces on every tv
channel in every newspaper the system is
broken
we know it's broken and we don't care
because even
aoc and josh hawley i criticized them
earlier and and i'll define them in a
second but listen
they both tweeted about how this was
awful they're doing this 5543 or
whatever pages
with only a couple hours to read it they
voted for it yeah so if you're going to
speak out against it come on vote no
like rand paul did like ted cruz did
like
uh you know i think it was like 65 or
more republicans only two democrats
voted no and it was tulsi gabbard and
rishi taleb
now in their defense at least they spoke
up against it
hundreds of other members of congress
voted for a ridiculous
omnibus 2.3 trillion garbage bill that
includes things like this
this is from the foundation for economic
education 10 million dollars for gender
programs in pakistan
wonderful that's exactly what the
american people have been begging for
they've been
coming together and rising up these
conservative protesters in oregon i know
what they were really saying
kate brown we want gender diversity
programs in pakistan
10 million dollars i know it's not going
to change the change changing face of
the country
it's it's uh this is this is the this is
my next look so here's the deal
right the american people for uh the
better part of a year
have gone bankrupt have seen their small
businesses close
in western pennsylvania in my district
i've seen food lines every single week
thousands of people are struggling to
put food on the table
for their families the american people
are hurting and optically
this is what you do at a time when the
american people are hurting when they're
desperate for relief
not only do you give them 600 bucks and
by the way like to anybody that's
that's watching right now if you take
the just the the 900 billion dollar plus
coveted relief right
and you just do the quick math uh 330
million people that's 2 700 bucks for
every man woman and child in america
right they could have given us 2 700
bucks
now instead of doing that the government
took
twenty seven hundred dollars from every
man woman and child in america
and gave you six hundred dollars back it
would be like i said merry christmas
that's unacceptable in every way it
would be like if i robbed you
at gunpoint took your wallet took all
your cash out
and then said here's 20 bucks you went
awesome thank you so much
right and so to to your point of
building schools for afghan children is
amazing teaching little girls to read in
afghanistan is great because we want to
make sure that we shape that next
generation but
do it in a different bill timing and
optics are important like
you're looking at 700 million dollars
through sudan 1.4 billion to the asia
reassurance initiative act which again
the asia reassurance initiative act i
don't have a problem with really what it
what it basically is
it funds counter insurgency in asia
basically keeps an eye on china i got no
issues with that but
don't put it in a covid relief bill the
problem with these omnibus spending
bills
right is that congress doesn't read them
they don't have enough time to read them
and because our representatives the
people that we send to washington
to do our work for us and look out for
us the people don't know what's in them
either
and nobody does and here's omnibus
spending bills only get bigger
they don't get smaller which is why our
debt in the last 10 years has gone from
11 trillion
to 27 trillion dollars now that now the
debt to
uh to gdp ratio is the scarier thing 128
percent right yeah so we're generating
massive debt and we're producing nothing
and that is how you kill economies this
is this that's how you kill economies
this is a national security issue
and this will become probably the
greatest leadership challenge
of of our time and you know
i am gravely concerned with
with the amount of debt that we're
racking up in this country and bills
like this
don't help trying to explain it to
people is it's it's
it's it's such a genius move on the part
of the criminal
mass wearing bandits who just ripped us
off to to quote the babylon bee
yeah yeah because what they've done is
they've found a way to extract the
the value of labor from the working
class in a way they don't notice
so i i have i've you know there's like
this one guy i know i was arguing with
and he's like why are they only giving
us 600 dollars and i was like no they're
not giving you 600
brother they're taking 2 700 and giving
you 600 back yeah and you and
they don't understand like what do you
mean they're writing me a check i'm
getting money
listen they they've printed 35
of all u.s dollars in in circulation
have been
printed in the last 10 months so that's
all happening right now
and that dilutes your buying power it
basically is a blanket wage reduction
but it's smart a working-class person
get 10 bucks an hour like or you know a
person barely
depending on how many hours they were
could be in poverty levels they get 10
bucks an hour and they're saying i want
15.
i want 15 bucks an hour and then they do
something like this
that that 10 bucks an hour can now buy
you seven dollars worth of groceries
from the year before
and they don't realize they think well
i'm still getting the same rate
i had i'll tell you this man i was
shopping on amazon
and i was buying a tablet and so i
clicked it and it went into my shopping
cart
and then something happened i forgot
about it a day or so later i opened up
amazon
again and it said price changes in your
cart the tablet went from 500 to 650
that's that's the kind of thing i'm
talking about people don't get it for a
working class person for somebody who's
making 10 50 bucks an hour
that could be another week they have to
work another week to get the tablet so
they could do the job
and if you if you can't get access to
tools like that i mean i'll tell you
if you get a good phone a good
smartphone you can make good youtube
videos you can start a career you can
start a podcast
if you can get the if you can get some
basic you know cheap cheap equipment
i started doing everything i was doing
with just a cell phone not very good one
either just like a
basic smartphone i saved up and i bought
it imagine if
before i was able to buy it this crisis
happened
and then i go into the store and i'm
like i finally saved up the 300 bucks
for the phone they go it's 450 now i
would have been like
i guess no phone for me then i wouldn't
have started live streaming then i
wouldn't have started building up this
company and then it wouldn't even happen
for me you know what i mean
so there there there is a certain uh
degree of
having to earn and save to invest in
yourself invest in a business
they're extracting the buying power from
the working class rich people are going
to be fine
rich people can buy stocks i mean i'm
telling you man
if you and bought amazon stock if you
bought bitcoin
you're you're sitting back and you're
laughing at all this well
i mean what what concerns me is that
six hundred dollars is i feel like
insulting
you know and and what's more
is that nancy pelosi was was given a
better deal
nine what six months ago but sat on it
the democrats in congress sat
on it did nothing with it because she
wanted to score cheap political points
against the president
didn't want to give him an economic win
before november 3rd
so what what the democrats and look
but come on sean could you imagine if
donald trump would have won
i mean the nightmare of this cheeto
fascist winning the american people
gladly
uh for went or this this this uh
1200 stimulus package in october because
they knew
it was for the greater good right
defeating donald trump
no no no you know i mean
i'm telling you i i see this i see this
pain in in pennsylvania
every single day i mean i these people i
reach out to them i
they call me on my cell phone i'm you
know like i said i i've tried to lead on
this issue and be there for them through
this time of crisis and again not just
for republicans but for democrats too
but to be
clear the democrats and the house of
representatives
sat on covet relief because they didn't
want to give
president trump an economic victory
before november 3rd
the reason why that was important tim is
they made the political calculation
that yes the american people are going
to have to suffer even people that are
democrats that will likely vote for us
they're going to have to suffer for the
next six months so that we can beat
donald trump
i find that i was joking of course i
know i know i know some people might not
realize
but uh think about that the democrats
nancy pelosi held the american people
hostage
and here's what i love i i love hearing
this from these just like urban leftist
types
i call the you know what i want to try
and differentiate between
the actual economic left
who do pay attention to politics and
maybe we have disagreements on policy
but there's political commentators they
they they know a decent amount of their
stuff maybe
we think they don't know as much or or
whatever but you have these like low
information resistance type democrats
that they're they're not particularly
politically active and they're
complaining they're saying but nancy
pelosi passed her bill
earlier this year and mcconnell wouldn't
approve of it
and it's like what was in that bill what
that that was
that bill was the same problem we're
seeing with this garbage omnibus
they put a bunch of trash in it knowing
the republicans could not allow it to
pass well of course do you know what the
major sticking point and what nancy
pelosi's bill was is she wanted bailouts
for
for poorly run radical liberal cities so
but she wanted to get rid of voter uh
she wanted to to get rid of voter id
laws well yeah that was all crammed in
there too
nonsensical things that put your relief
bill what i told people in pennsylvania
and in my district
and in my opponent at the time was a big
proponent of taking
taxpayer dollars from the people of
pennsylvania and bailing out a city like
portland
that had already defunded their police
and let their city burn for
six months it's immoral to take
our tax dollars from hard-working people
in western pennsylvania who are already
struggling to bail out poorly run
liberal cities that's the major point or
how about to fund
gender diversity programs in pakistan
yeah i mean
yes i mean so yes optically we're back
to the to the covet bill it was an
it's an absolute disaster um and
my fear is is is that problems like this
are only going to get worse and the
point that i was making before this is
that
it's looking like look i i don't know
what the future holds and
you know that uh i'm i'm a supporter of
president trump
uh i've talked to the president on
multiple occasions i'm always going to
fight for the people of this country
i i believe uh
in president trump and but
it's amazing now that some of the more
career politicians in washington they
see the writing on the wall
they see president trump that maybe in
january
you know you've got a guy like joe biden
that that likely be sworn in as
president
did you see with this bill how fast the
swamp
on both sides of the aisle went back to
being
the swamp oh yeah right we didn't see
irresponsible spending bills like this
in the news
for four years under president trump
don't get me wrong this is one of the
areas where i disagree with the
president
a lot is is his spending he spends a lot
more than i'm comfortable with and so i
i disagree with him on a lot on deficit
spending and things like that but i
would also argue that
in the middle of a crisis and a pandemic
once a hundred year pandemic that this
the times like this are precisely meant
for deficit spending
but but my my point is the swamp has
gone back to being the swamp in record
time
so i i remember uh talking to uh some
family
earlier this year and they were saying
you always rag on democrats
all you do is democrats this democrats
that and i'm like i
i criticize republicans admittedly you
do much less than i criticize democrats
and i'm going to show everybody
listening exactly why i
am right i have here from govtrack.ushr
133 consolidated appropriations act 2021
including coronavirus stimulus and
relief
we can see in the senate 46 democrats
vote yay
two independents which who caucuses the
democrats vote yay
44 republicans vote yay but what's this
six republicans
uh voted nay and two republicans
abstained
at least we have them and i'll give a
shout
out to rick scott rand paul marsha
blackburn ted cruz mike lee and ron
johnson
now those politicians are not far from
perfect you can criticize them for a
bunch of different things
but at least they have the political
willpower to say i'm not signing this
thing
yeah it gets better gets better we jump
over to
the house vote hr 133 and once again
we have 128 republicans yay 230
democrats yay one independent yay
we have 50 republicans nay rejecting
this
17 republicans abstain grow a spine guy
say no
and then only two democrats actually
voted against this
of all of congress we ended up with 56
republicans saying no
and what was that what was the uh let's
let's pull this back up and get the
abstaining we had two abstentions so 19
republicans abstained from the vote
and only two democrats and it was tulsi
gabbard who i am a big fan of and have
praised
and rashida taleb who have been very
critical of but my respect to her for
saying no to this
i don't know what her reasons were and
each one of these politicians might have
a different reason
but ultimately saying no to this garbage
was the right thing
well yeah i mean again because
coveted relief should be for coveted
relief
exactly there are lots of and it should
be bigger and it should be for the
american people
look i i i think that we should have
done direct payments to the american
people i like
2 400 bucks uh for for people i think
that was president trump's number in the
in the past something that is that can
actually help them pay their bills uh
what i really liked
is the paytech protection program uh and
in fact
before this bill was voted on uh the
democrats
in the house of representatives i think
voted against at least twice perhaps a
third time
uh extensions of the pay tech protection
protection program which would simply
have extended the program through the
end of the year
right real simple vote extend the
program through the end of the year and
streamline the forgiveness process
right the democrats in the house of
representatives voted against that three
times
and so i got massive problems with that
uh
lydia pulled up the story from news wkrg
g5
what's uh what's the date on this this
is from december 22nd
trump calls on congress to amend covet
19 relief bill to increase
stimulus checks to 2000 per person
remove wasteful and unnecessary items
but you see what rand paul's response to
all this was if six hundred why not
twelve hundred twelve months right now
ten thousand yeah twenty thousand why
not universal basic income
i mean you could fix this problem
tomorrow if you just adopted a more
surgical
pandemic response and so i i will say
that i think the political motivations
in blue states and governors like
newsom pritzker in illinois uh cuomo in
new york
wolf in in my home state of pennsylvania
i believe that these second lockdowns
are not just because of the coronavirus
i believe that they're making a
political calculation and trying to put
pressure on mitch mcconnell
to bail out you know as i mentioned
poorly run liberal states in liberal
cities
you know by locking down the economy
more right
it puts more pressure on small
businesses more pressure on mr mcconnell
to bail
to give him what give those governors
what they want
i i've i've thought about you know we we
went to the first lockdown so let's
let's let's let's uh we'll use a segue
into the the big story that we want to
talk about
i remember earlier this year watching
videos coming out of china
where it's like someone's on a bus and
they point the camera out the window and
then someone just falls over and it was
like watching sean of the dead i don't
know if you guys have seen that movie
where he's like riding and he sees the
person fall over and he's like looking
we saw a bunch of those videos it was
freaky and what was happening is that
people were having respiratory issues
from coven and then just like
earlier in the year we had a very
serious problem so we all agreed okay
we're going to lock down for 15 days
because we can't stop this thing right i
didn't agree with that by the way
well i did because i the idea was
flattened a curve right how many how
many people forgot that already
it didn't work well it did work kova
just went haywire anyway
it went haywire okay it came back and so
what happened was we did flatten the
curve
and then we had this big flat period and
now it's spiking again proving
it's not going to stop and we can't just
stay locked down
forever so the the appropriate response
now i believe
is protect the vulnerable social
distancing masks and reopening
everything well
so so i think let go back to the just go
back to the very beginning
in january um i saw
what i saw coming out of china uh was
very concerning to me
and the truth is i didn't know nor did
anybody else to include our intelligence
community what we were dealing with in
covet and i think back then we didn't
even have a name for it
um and so tom cotton and i think i i
think tom cotton and i were the first
people in the country to say
we need to ban all travel from china
yeah until we can figure this out and
they got mad at soundcloud oh
they got mad at tom cotton they got mad
at me over xenophobic and then i think
the president a couple days later band
travel from china
uh this was all while impeachment uh
articles of impeachment by the way were
being delivered from
the house to the senate uh and then the
president in an address in fact i was in
washington dc at the time
and the president banned all travel from
europe and i remember
watching that thinking oh my god this is
serious he's doing a presidential dress
banning all travel from europe is a big
deal yeah definitely
um and this was at the time where nancy
pelosi was passing out impeachment pens
and telling people to go out in
chinatown and mayor de blasio saying go
see a movie
um come on down to chinatown again
calling calling donald trump xenophobic
a hysterical
xenophobic but i know i know that the
media loves to push this fake fact check
where they're like biden never called
trump xenophobic yeah
to specify he in response to trump's
call for banning travel
uh to china joe biden said we don't need
donald trump xenophobia
so it was very clear he was calling
trump a xenophobe in response to this
but the media goes but he didn't call
him that he said he was ex
okay shut up media yeah so so my point
is is that i
i was okay with the lockdowns early on
precisely because we didn't know enough
about the virus i mean for god's sake it
could have had a fifty percent fatality
right yeah and in those instances
just from a strategic pandemic military
response standpoint
when you don't know a whole lot about
the pathogen you want to make sure that
you protect people and keep them
isolated as long as possible until you
learn
about what this thing can do my point is
after 15 days to slow the spread then 30
days to slow the spread then two months
to slow their spread then six months
but the point is we know a lot more
about covet 19 today than we did in
january
we know how it would affect yeah we've
got therapeutics regeneron i mean uh
we've we've got uh hydroxychloroquine by
the way which is
the ama came back now now now it's cool
because the pres
because yeah the the election's over
hydraulic and actually the american
medical association reversed their
previous advice on
exactly hydrochloroquine amazing exactly
and so not only that now we've got two
effective uh vaccines and by the way you
know people that criticize the
president's
pandemic response again does president
trump always say the right thing no
uh but his this public-private
partnership
uh uh project airbridge was an
unprecedented success
i mean he delivered pp uh personal
protective equipment ppe
uh at levels that we never thought
possible by simply
partnering with private institutions to
make them available when he got
criticized no no
they're not being enough personal
protective equipment democrats were
actually praising him
we had cuomo and newsome actually oh
it's a time right right right at the
time yes they were crazy
and fauci said we're doing a great job i
don't think anybody could do anything
better
we developed so many ventilators in this
country in such a short amount of time
that we didn't even come close to using
what we created and what we made
we sent them all around the world do you
remember the hospital ships up in new
york city and outside l.a do you know
how many people went on the uss
conference
like like one patient right now i don't
even think it was a covet patient
right the javits center had like 30
capacity yeah and operation warp speed
was an unprecedented success all of this
stuff
happened under president trump's
leadership the development of of
personal protective equipment which by
the way
uh our national stockpile of personal
protective equipment was completely
depleted by obama under obama and joe
biden under the h1n1
think about this okay donald trump uh i
i remember getting a twitter argument
with some some
leftist and i said donald trump did a
good job on covid
and their only response was oh my god
are you serious and i was like
so we had a lefty on the show and the
first thing he brought up was i
understand
like when he was addressing it there's
no metric by which to judge
a good job or a bad job because
it's one leader it's one president doing
this one thing you can try and compare
it to historic historical moments or
whatever and
you can't do it right so i'm like you're
correct i i agree with that
and he goes and that being said here's
why trump did a bad job and i said well
i think trump did a good job
it's really about whether you like trump
that's what it boils down
to is it trump's comportment um people
you know and i'll tell you because we
experienced this on the campaign trail
um
i don't know what it is i mean i think
when you talk about the president's
achievements whether it's project
airbridge or operation warp speed
or or uh some of these unprecedented
public-private partnerships or
ventilator
uh uh production like all of these
things i mean were happened in record
time i mean
the fact that we have two vaccines
available to people in under a year
is is close to a miracle it happened
under president trump's leadership
but but people don't people didn't like
him at the podium during press
conference shortly yeah i know they
didn't
like they didn't like how he interacted
with the media and so that was
enough for people to say well i just
i just i just i just don't like i don't
i don't think he's doing a good job
thanks for checking out this clip from
the tim cast irl podcast we do the show
live
monday through friday at 8pm so come
back to check us out when we go live
don't forget to subscribe hit the like
button hit the notification bell
and we are also available on all podcast
platforms for free
if you want to listen to us there thanks
for hanging out and we will see you all
next time
you